we're really excited about this study we
just completed in which we were for the
first time able to track single neurons
as they're kind of being placed within
the brain the field has known for many
years that these neurons are very
precisely placed but how that precise
placement happens it's not really well
understood we were able to collaborate
with physicists to develop these
microscopes that enabled very gentle
Imaging throughout development to be
able to capture those early events let
me show you how how these videos look we
can see early on the first neurons
appearing and the neurons growing out
into what will be the brain and then we
were able to label single cells and
understand how is this cell selecting
its placement and then it was through a
process that we called retrograde
zippering it's like it looks very much
like zippering backwards you know
include the way that you close a gene
for example
here we're seeing this blue neuron
and it's gonna sipper backwards starting
at that point where that green arrow is
as to meet that other ping neuron that
is in the correct neighborhood you can
see it actually closing the Gap that
black space there as it's now meeting
the correct neighborhood this is very
important what we're able to do with
this microscope is track those events as
they're actually occurring and ascribe
specific genetic functions to these
molecules that we're identifying in that
sequence of events if your car breaks
down the reason that a mechanic can
actually fix the car is because there
was an engineer that built the car and
they understand how the car works so
over here we have a system that we
didn't build we cannot ask the engineer
so we have to reverse engineer how it
works to be able to understand first how
it functions and then how it functions
incorrectly which has implications to
diseases such as autism
neurodevelopmental disorders mental
retardation Etc but it's it's a
fundamental question that we need to
understand if we have an aspiration to
be able to understand how these circuits
form and how they form incorrectly in
early developmental diseases
thank you